[Music]
are you I am sitting next to the
incredibly good-looking cast of the
upcoming Transformers spin-off bus stop
which is being released this December
how are you guys thanks so much for
being here very good thank you thank you
this movie is so highly anticipated I am
personally so excited when I watched the
trailer I literally got chills when I
heard the Labor Day max voice and it
just feels like such a coming-of-age
movie and I really got Iron Giant vibes
is that the tone of this movie is this
maybe gonna be like The Iron Giant that
I mean that is an aspect of it yes I
mean it is sort of modeled after those
classic Amblin Spielberg in
coming-of-age tales of the 80s you know
things like ET Iron Giant is in that
similar kind of vein you know that
experience that we go through as we're
transitioning from one phase in our life
to the next and it felt like the perfect
kind of setting and story to set this
origin story for bumblebee in that kind
of framework and Haley's character
Charlie and bumblebee they meet each
other they're both these kind of broken
souls and over the course of this
adventure they heal each other it's a
really lovely and action-packed story
we're so excited for it since it's in
80s will we see bumblebee and a pair of
parachute pants or a Members Only jacket
maybe yeah you're gonna have to see the
movie boy I'm not gonna say no I'm not
gonna say yes well the 80s were a time
where the Transformers were basically I
wouldn't know but I've heard the best
new friend that any human could have
some curious to know George since we
weren't around in the 80s what is
everyone's first connection to the
Transformers line would be when they
came up and literally because you could
get two toys for the price of one toy so
with four brothers and a very busy
household and everyone trying to get
what they could you with transformers
you could literally have two toys for
one toy so that's I can vividly remember
wanting transformers for that reason
right yeah for me was a Transformers our
motto which was I think the second
version of the TV show that one didn't
have bumblebee but I had hot shot so
when the movies came out I was really
like super confused but uh yeah that was
a fun time I remember that and then the
I think the McDonald's toys had
transformers for a bit so that was that
was my first time I'd always pick the
boys happy man I got the good size it's
interesting because the transformers
universe has now been around for about
35 years so it's funny did you have
these different iterations people came
of age with these toys with these
characters and the stories at different
points for some people it's Michael's
films their first exposure to
transformers for me and for John it was
the first time transformers were
launched in America and yeah I was a kid
when those toys came you know came onto
the market the animated series the comic
books came out and I absolutely loved
that I've never seen anything like it
and for us setting this film in that era
it allowed us to go back to that kind of
feel that kind of aesthetic and that
kind of a vibe that you get from that
initial that at that initial launch of
the film why they were so wondrous and
so special right my parents always tried
me they always had the generic versions
it's certainly we won't name them oh yes
yeah few Gobots myself you're ruining my
life we have the generic of everything I
still know what Froot Loops taste like
you know they have grocery stores and
you can actually buy a box of Froot
Loops if you're so inclined I know I
should I should do that don't do it
don't do it I know right I feel
different flavored circles let's talk
about bumblebee that is the name of this
movie this is his origin story why do
you think a bumblebee deserve the
spin-off over any other transformer so
my perspective yeah well from you too
John you know cuz if bumblebee is a fan
favorite well and why do we love
bumblebee so much in doing these
interviews I think traps explains it
extremely well and I can honestly say
that I feel the same way and he's the
captain of the ship so I feel like he
has to answer sorry I will say I agree
with him before he answers because I've
heard his answer before but he's a
hundred percent right well you know from
my perspective he's the most interesting
transformer in the sense that he's that
with the one transfer who has the
deepest amenity for Humanity who has the
greatest connection with people and I
was I thought that was really
interesting from his Oh from the first
time we see him in the animated series
he immediately attaches to this human
and it got anything why is that what can
we explore what is about him and who he
is we was before we got to know him and
who he is you know after this experience
that turns him into this kind of person
what is it about you I thought I thought
that was a fascinating thing to lead
into and this film does it's an origin
story explains who he was before we got
to know him and over the course of this
this journey he becomes the bumblebee
that we know and lost this is his origin
story are we gonna get to hear his voice
I did you just ask a question because I
didn't hear anything so if you didn't
ask a question I can't answer it so I
never heard what sound makes you guys
think of the Transformers because for me
it's the voice of Optimus Prime that's a
good one are we gonna see Optimus I can
confirm that Optimus does make is
something of an appearance a cameo of
sorts yes we have a lot of wonderful
little Easter eggs that are kind of laid
out throughout the film you don't need
to know anything about the Transformers
to enjoy it
they're a lot of fun things for fans
like me and for fans of the series there
are a lot of fun aspects of the the
whole franchise that we weave into the
narrative right um George I'm curious to
know more about your characters your
character of a name and can we know more
about he does actually that's a very
good question his name is memo I'm new
to the neighborhood in this new origin
story I'm actually new to Haley's
character Charlie's neighborhood I think
that she's a great person I'm vying for
her attention and my you know my my
search to get her attention kind of
leads me into this big bumblebee
adventure and I kind of get dragged
along and things ensue John I want to
know more about your character too
because we know there are three
Decepticons so how does agent burns kind
of play into all of this I can't tell
you anything at this time which is
horrible
so it makes this like weird knock word
because you're looking be like are you
really gonna not tell me anything I've
been sworn to secrecy if there's a group
of people that travel around with
briefcases handcuffed to their arm and
there's just agreements that I've signed
not to say anything until it's time to
say something we have we have an
exposition of footage later on this
afternoon
so if this were later on in the
space-time continuum then enable talk to
maybe a bit more but until then
such a mystery just like your Instagram
account Travis is obviously first
live-action without Michael Bay oh yeah
first live-action without Michael Bay so
I needed to know who was more of a diva
on set John Cena or bumblebee well
considering the fact that bumblebee was
never on set he actually is a CG
animated character magic I guess it
would have to be John know I will take
that claim I was definitely more of a
diva on set I can't confirm nor deny
that I am playing neither a villain nor
hero I'm good now I'm good thanks Haley
how does that feel to be the first
female lead of a transformers movie well
wouldn't I hear it out loud like that
it's pretty insane I feel very fortunate
to have been given the opportunity to
play this role of this character Charlie
Watson in bumblebee she she really she's
really a special character she's got a
lot to say and and unique ways of saying
it so I'm excited for people to meet her
can you tell us more about Charlie aside
from oh is she more of like a tomboy
yeah she's definitely definitely more of
a tomboy she really is your typical sort
of misunderstood teenager and there's
this freedom that she absolutely craves
and basically finds her way into that
and that's that's through a car and then
obviously that car turns into something
other than a car and there's this
budding friendship and journey within
all of that so she plays a mechanic so
how are you with cars in real life
how are your driving skills well I will
say my my brother is a mechanic in a
racecar driver so I was like how do I
put this lightly but no that's what he
does so I he was on set with me when I
made this movie and I constantly was
calling him and to set to help me with
lines and make sure that he could
explain and Britt there was at one point
he was like printing out like I mean
definitions and graphs and outlines of
cars and everything to explain to me
what everything was so he he was my
little cheat sheet on this movie so it
sounds like the best brother ever
do you have a love interest in this film
um that part I'm not going to tell you
there is tons of emotion though and love
and I mean heartfelt everything in this
movie there are relationships there are
conflicts and inner obstacles and outer
obstacles with Charlie and her friends
and her family and people that she likes
and and and stuff like that but um that
part you're gonna have to wait and see
I'm so excited because it seems like
there's way more emotion in this movie
than what we're used to how is this
movie stylistically different from the
transformer movies we've seen in the
past
well you said it perfectly just and it
has it has a lot of emotion it's it's
you know it's an origin story and it's
very character driven and storyline
driven and yeah I mean it all stems
around this this girl and and who she is
in her family and and her way of finding
who she is in life right when we think
Transformers movies we think huge epic
scale action seas are we gonna get that
in this absolutely absolutely um
Transformers fans will definitely get
their their taste of that of what the
Transformers films are known for so
there is definitely a bit of action I
was able to partake in some of it which
was exciting and the whole the whole
shoot was really I mean everyday you
kind of never really knew what was gonna
happen and filming something like this
where I mean you want to say 90% of the
film is in is in special effects it's
like I can't wait to see the final
product of this because it'll be as if
you know I don't know the story
necessarily in a way because it's kind
of like I can't wait to see what they
put in around me I hope what I imagined
was somewhat correct right well this
movie obviously takes place in the 80s
and we weren't around then so how are
you able to connect to the era um well
first of all our director Travis Knight
he was himself a child of the 80s so he
was able to break down the specifics for
us but also just really being able to
immerse myself in that in that era I
find it pretty fascinating myself in
terms of the style and
music so I had a great time you know
going back to that but my character
Charlie we it was it was one of my
favorite parts and developing her was
you know with the the hair and the
makeup and the Wardrobe from our vision
boards basically consisted of Debbie
Harry Madonna and I mean just iconic
women of the 80s and I loved being able
to like go on the trailer everyday and
see them and have that be the sort of
inspiration stylistically for this
character you're obviously an incredible
singer do you have any music in the
movie my lips are sealed on that um the
music obviously plays a huge role in
this movie so I I'm hoping you know the
movies in post-production right now so
everything is kind of in its final
stages of coming together so if there's
an opportunity to to be involved in that
sense then absolutely I'd love to so my
favorite part of the trailer was at the
very end when Charlie basically Rick
rolls bumblebee okay do you know what
rickrolling
I don't but I was gonna act like I did
I'm glad you mentioned it cuz I really
know I did when you click on a link on
the internet and you think it's gonna be
one thing but really it's that song by
Rick Astley god I'm gonna give you up
right so you basically Rick Rolled
bumblebee hey I'm gonna use that like
that
are there any transformers that you can
tease that maybe in this movie that we
might see oh well there are there are um
we learned that Optimus is makes a
little cameo in the movie sure there are
a couple little cameos here and there
that I think people will be really
excited about and yes optimises is in
there so um yeah I mean I guess I'll
have to wait and see all right well we
are so excited
you